you know the kids today don't know how
good the internet used to be
I don't think this is just all right
come on like everyone's nostalgic for
their past but I actually think the
internet before small groups of
weaponized corporate and government
interests took it over was a beautiful
place
you know those small number of companies
have created some sexy products
but you're saying overall in the long
Arc of History the centralization of
power they have
like suffocated the human Spirit at
scale here's a question to ask about
those beautiful sexy products imagine
two thousand Google to 2010 Google right
a lot changed we got Maps we got Gmail
we lost a lot of products too I think
from yeah I mean some were probably
we've got Chrome right and now let's go
from 2010 we got Android now let's go
from 2010 to 2020.
what does Google have well search engine
Maps mail Android and chrome oh I see
the internet was this
you know I was times person of the year
in 2006.
yeah I love this it's you this time's
first of the year in 2006 all right like
like that's you know so quickly did
people forget and I think some of its
social media I think some of it I I hope
look I hope that I I don't it's possible
that some very Sinister things happen I
don't I don't know I think it might just
be like the effects of social media and
but something happened in the last 20
years
oh okay so you're just being an old man
who's worried about the I think there's
always it goes it's the cycle thing it's
ups and downs and I think people
ReDiscover the power of distributed of
decentralized yeah I mean that's kind of
like what the the whole like
cryptocurrency is trying like did that
I think crypto is just carrying the
flame of that Spirit of like self should
be essential just it's just such a shame
that they all got rich
you know yeah if you took all the money
out of crypto it would have been a
beautiful place yeah no I mean these
people you know they they sucked all the
value out of it and took it
yeah money kind of corrupts the Mind
somehow it becomes this drug you've
corrupted all of crypto you had coins
worth billions of dollars that had zero
use
you still have hope for crypto sure I
have hope for the ideas I really do
um yeah I mean you know
I want the US dollar to collapse
I do